[Music]
uh morning to you nadine doris in just a
moment
or two but before that we want to bring
you the very latest on our polling pit
stop that we do at this time every day
patrick english is here with us um hi
patrick a very good morning to you what
is what is the latest perlin what are
the today good morning yes so our latest
figures from hugo that released
yesterday we looked into how favorable
are unfavorable the candidates are with
the general public and crucially with
swing voters so these people who might
have voted conserved in 2019 are now
telling us that they're not or people
who went from labour who took that
journey under boris johnson from labour
in 2017 to conservatives in 2019 and
what we found is that among those groups
in particular rishi sunak does have an
advantage in terms of his favorability
he is more popular than his trust now it
should be said this trust his name
recognition is a little bit lower so she
has room to grow or she has room also to
get more negative but at the moment as
it stands with the public and
particularly with those swing voters
rishi sunak does have a bit of an edge
give me the numbers
so at the moment what we're looking at
is about a 20-point gap for russia sunax
he's on about -25 among those voters who
were voting con 17 2019 are now telling
us that they're going to vote labor if
the election will be held tomorrow this
trust however is on minus 45. so it's
not really too much of a close race
there which is doing very well and then
of course boris johnson
he's at minus 90. so that kind of
highlights i think the problem that the
conservative party has at the moment
with the candidates that are putting
forward none of them are very popular
with the voters that need to win back if
they're going to have any chance of
defending that majority of the next
election and you delve deeper into the
numbers as well didn't you what else did
you find
yes we did so
what we found is that boris johnson is
not very popular at all with the general
public he's at -45 so we're thinking
about conservative voters who say they
prefer out of these three we've seen
some polling that suggests that boris
johnson would be ahead but really when
we ask the public in terms of the
favorability boris johnson is at minus
45 right so he's down there whereas
rishi sunak and his trust are at -30. so
we can't characterize any of these
politicians as particularly popular
however we can say that sunak and trust
are more popular than johnson among the
general public okay and astronauts
kirsten is concerned kierstarma he is in
right well kind of right in a pretty
decent position compared to these
politicians we have here so he's at
minus 19 with the general public however
among those
people who we say are undecided at the
minute who did vote conservation 2019
but don't know who they vote for now
he's all the way down at -59 so
certainly the public that section of the
public who don't know who they vote for
who did well conservative 19 and not at
all convinced by kirsten okay it's good
to see you thanks very much indeed
that's our polling pit stop for this
morning let's bring in nadine doris
should we secretary of state for digital
culture media and sport good morning to
you thanks for joining us on the
programme uh this morning we want to
talk about the commonwealth games of
course but can i just pick up on that
polling apparently boris johnson is not
at all popular with the public what
would you say to that
well i say there's only one poll which
ever matters kay and that's the poll
that takes place during a general
election and boris johnson won as an
80-seat majority at the last general
election less than three years ago there
are polls come and go and and i'm afraid
i don't actually take an awful lot of
notice of them because there's only one
that matters and and as you know we won
an 80-seat majority
absolutely um
yes indeed um he's going to be finding
it hard to celebrate the commonwealth
games though isn't he because of what
what has happened uh what has the nation
lost do you think as far as boris
johnson is concerned when he resigned
so i think he lost somebody who took us
through a pandemic who gave the
conservative party my party an 80-seat
majority something that hasn't happened
since the
40 years he gave us a mandate he took us
through a pandemic which has had global
repercussions he led us and and was the
first global leader to help ukraine and
and helped us lead a um
an effort to support ukraine through
putin's barbaric attack he ensured and
guaranteed that we were the first
country in the world to get a
vaccination into somebody's arm as part
of the the war on covid
and and also help to take us into
economic growth out of the pandemic so i
think boris johnson's achieved a huge
amount and and for me they are the signs
of a great leader what they achieve when
they're in office and i think he did
that you were devastated weren't you
when it happened tell us how you felt
um i was very disappointed i thought it
was a huge mistake but what i would say
is that
in this trust
we have somebody who has both integrity
and loyalty and is is
is able to pick up the baton using those
very important qualities to take the
country forward so i think you know what
happened has happened we have to look to
the future now and for me personally i'm
looking to liz trust who i think has
many of those qualities and and will be
able to step into the role as prime
minister from day one hit the ground
running and be able to deal with some of
the very complex problems that we're
facing as a nation as a result of a
global pandemic and because of the war
in ukraine the effects of which are
still going on today and we will still
feel for the future to come
to what extent do you blame rishi sunak
for um boris johnson's demise
so look i don't want to get into the so
as you can see k behind me there are
dancers
yeah i'll come on to that as i said
right at the beginning i'm asking you
whether to what extent do you blame
rishi sunat for boris johnson's demise
so it is it is not a secret that um that
we that things that things happen that
shouldn't have happened and that um
boris johnson was removed by a coup but
i don't know if you can hear behind me
but i'm in birmingham and today is the
first day of the commonwealth games
which is going to be the most successful
games commonwealth games ever to have
been held i'm going to talk about that
including volunteers and athletes
i want to know what you think about
rishi sunak and where what uh to what
extent he uh was responsible for the
demise of boris johnson and then we will
come on to the uh uh games in the
fullness of time
look kay i don't want to um today
because it's the opening of the
commonwealth games because we have the
lionesses going to wembley on sunday
because these few days are going to be
fantastic at sporting events not just
for sport not just the commonwealth but
for women particularly today is the day
i don't want to engage in the leadership
i want to talk about the really
important things that are happening here
in birmingham and the west midlands and
and in wembley on sunday because
i'm the secretary of state for gcms this
is what my department has been working
on we even have one of our own civil
servants competing from my department in
the commonwealth to games today for me
the next few days are not about
leadership they're about showcasing what
is great about this country what is
great about the west midlands and what
is the important things that are
happening here in birmingham today
so the leadership race isn't important
for the next few days
so the leadership race is going to go on
all through the summer and will conclude
on september the 5th at which point we
will have a new leader and a new prime
minister for the next few days please
forgive me but i am going to focus on
what we've been working on in my
department
for years before i arrived you know we
delivered these games in four and a half
years it takes seven normally we
delivered them on budget the
government's invested over 600 million
pounds in these games for me that today
is an important day it's the opening of
something we've been working on as a
government honors department over a
number of years um i mean forgive me i
want to focus on the positives about
what's happening here the athletes who
are here competing the thousands of
volunteers that we have working here and
the buzz which is in this city today
there's been nothing as big as this in
this country since 2012 in the olympics
it's a really important day and i think
we should be focusing on the positives
and shall we be spending 778 million
pounds on a vanity project
it's not a vanity project okay come on
this is this is hugely important you're
saying we shouldn't have the
commonwealth games i think we are proud
and honored to have picked up the baton
when it was dropped elsewhere in the
world and to continue to run these
commonwealth games in the amazing way
that we have done everybody here
thousands of people are extremely proud
including the volunteers behind me right
now extremely proud of what we're doing
and you know the common world it's an
important organization particularly in
light of what's happening globally on
the geopolitical front and particularly
with russia and china and the war in
ukraine it's more important than ever
and these games they symbolize that they
symbolize they're coming together of
those nature those nations so of course
it should be it's not a vanity project
it's an important project it's one we
should continue yesterday we had sam
terry on the programme he is a shadow
minister uh or was a shadow minister for
transport in the labour government he
got sacked after he talked to us this is
what happened
i've not been instant noble to anyone i
support kia osama i think he's by far
the best person to be prime minister of
this country i believe he will be the
prime minister of this country my job
today is to support transport workers as
a shadow transport minister to support
the travelling public every worker
deserves a pay rise that is in line with
inflation and at the moment the rmt and
tsa have been offered four percent this
year when inflation is running at 11 and
then at 2 on the following two years
that is a real terms pay cut no worker
should be offered a pay cut as a way
forward whilst having a sort of gun put
to their head in terms of losing their
jobs
now we can hear now we can hear me yeah
um
sam terry has been sacked by kierstarma
this was a tricky one for the labour
leader because there is this real split
in the labour party about rail strikes
and indeed the public sector strikes
we're seeing across the board um it was
his comments on sky news which did it
for him because not only had he defied
the leader saying don't go on the picket
line if you have a job in the shallow
cabinet or as a shadow minister but he
was standing there saying that if you
get a pay rise which is below inflation
then it's a real terms pay cut and
labour have been keen to do two things
one is to say we're not a party of
protest we're a party of government and
to stay away from the picket line but
also not to put a figure on exactly how
much rail workers should be paid we've
seen all these labour shadow cabinet
member saying we should make a deal but
not said what that deal should be
because they believe it should be up to
each union to negotiate the right deal
and we believe the rmt have actually
only asked for a seven percent rise so
they were angry that he did this media
round calling for basically an inflation
pay rise and so he has been fired but
the reaction from union leaders has been
pretty fierce kierstan was setting up a
battle with them we had the um tssa
union which is where sam terry in fact
used to work saying that labour are
deluded to think they can win the next
election without the support of union
members and they need to wake up and
smell the coffee and unite union which
is labour's biggest financial backer
saying this would be laughable if it
were not so serious so setting up a
battle perhaps a battle that plays well
for kierstarma to stand up to some on
the left in his party but certainly a
battle that's going to go on
others have been on the picket line as
well though haven't they we've seen
others other labour front benchers on
the picket line but they have been in
more junior positions and when they did
that in june with the first rail strike
they got reprimanded and i expect
they'll be reprimanded again i think
what um drove kierstama to sac sam tarry
was the fact that he was giving
interviews
basically making up policy on the hoof
about how much rail workers should be
paid so i think labour are just
reprimanding those who go on the picket
line they understand that many labour
mps want to show solidarity with
workers who were going on strike over
pay and conditions but this was too far
difficult though because uh sam terry is
thought to be in a relationship with
labour's deputy leader angela rayner
who's also tweeted her support for rail
workers who go on strike so there are
obviously differing views but the labour
leaders decided to take a stand and in
the process set up with big row with the
unions okay thanks for now tomorrow
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock uh still
to come on the program this hour though
we'll chat to the uh former labour
shadow chancellor that's john mcdonnell
bucky stama's decision to sack sam terry
for attending a picket line
just talking about that won't we and
we'll speak to the barrister adam wagner
about the change in the law that will
allow broadcasters to show the
sentencing remarks of judges in court
for the first time
how is climate change impacting the uk's
weather we'll speak to a climate
scientist that's mike kenden after the
met office released their state of the
uk report for 2021
there's a warning from the national grid
today that the uk could face a troubled
winter of energy supplies with tight
periods in supplying electricity it
comes as experts say bills could sort of
500 pounds a month from january
let's talk about it in more detail
maddie standing by for us at a power
station in northwest london this morning
hi um maddie very good morning it's
looking pretty bleak isn't it
it is certainly a very bleak outlook
this warning from the national grid that
electricity supply will be
tight this autumn this winter even comes
from its
winter outlook from the um
electricity systems operator and it says
it's basically going to be very hard for
them to meet the increased demand for
electricity over the winter months
especially at the beginning of december
but they should be able to keep the
lights on um don't know how encouraging
that is we've seen how vulnerable
britain's energy supply is to extreme
weather and just during the heat wave
even
last week and the week before
we had to pay the national grid had to
play belgium a record amount 5
000 more than usual to avoid a blackout
in london and it's all made worse by
russia's war in ukraine which has
destabilized the energy market and sent
prices much much higher even though the
uk itself doesn't source much of its gas
from russia but the end result is still
higher prices for households and we've
had warnings from several different
energy analysts about those higher
prices um cornwall insight suggesting
that the energy price cap that sort of
generic uh
cost of energy if you're on a
fixed price could be three that uh 3 500
pounds by october and last at that level
until 2024 another group has suggested
that energy bills could be 500 pounds a
month by january so households are
really going to hurt this is not good
news okay for now thank you thanks a lot
uh the met office published its annual
report and it shows the impact of global
warming on the uk climate is worsening
the state of the uk climate 2021
reported reaffirms climate change is not
just a future problem but is affecting
what we experience here at home already
here's katarina
today's met office report looks at last
year's weather but more crucially its
impact
2021 was another year in a pattern of
warming
that's changing things we take for
granted
spring is getting hotter and wetter
and the seasons are shifting now the
warmer weather has really sped up fruit
ripening and nuts for me now what that
means is it sounds well what's the
problem with that but actually that
happening earlier can have a really
disastrous effect for wildlife because
they may not have the food source
available later in autumn when they need
it so there's real jeopardy for some
species here yeah there's real jeopardy
or not we're in massive species decline
already
[Applause]
what's interesting about looking at last
year's weather is in some respects how
unremarkable it actually was in 2021
there were no extreme record highs but
why that is interesting is that if you
take that 12 months and look at it in a
broader context even without a record
high it was still one of the hottest
years on record
look at this at how much warmer 2021 was
than the average hottest day of the year
just a few decades ago
and remember today's report doesn't look
at this year 2022 that has already
changed the game entirely with the uk
average temperature exceeding 30 degrees
celsius for the first time ever
as climates change extremes become more
frequent last year saw storm irwin
batter parts of the uk with high winds
and snow eight months later just last
week it was that blistering heat
our natural world can adapt to gradual
change but shocks like extreme weather
in addition to our warming climate could
push some species too far to a point
beyond which they cannot recover
catherine over topsy sky news
and u.s politicians have reached an
agreement on an energy and climate tax
bill
uh that senate majority leader chuck
schumer of course and joe manchin's
agreement will raise taxes on high
earners and corporations and will reduce
federal debt both said the measure would
reduce carbon emissions by around 40
percent by 2030 which would still miss
president biden's 50 percent goal
meanwhile a wildfire has broken out in
idaho in the u.s around six miles north
of crane creek reservoir and has
currently spread around 1500 acres
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of the climate change
on the planet this is our calculator
that we uh show you every morning or
started to again you'll remember it from
last year as well this is the figure we
want to stay well below 1.5
degrees 1.25 at the moment that since
industrialization and uh co2 emissions
this is in millions of tons left hand
side over there that's the real-time
power mix for great britain this morning
using a lot of gas this morning and
almost 10 of renewables
importing very little
now england's lionesses will play
germany in sunday's euros 2022 final at
wembley
germany i beat france 2-1 in the semis
last night in milton keynes pushing
through to
play england at wembley could it be
coming home here's either
two very good teams and it was a good
season battle out and some good goals as
well that was great good it's a good one
is that is that is that the final you
want to see england will be germany yeah
not off our german fan here what's the
score going to be
for germany of course
don't forget it is on sunday wanted to
ask nadine doris about that as well
apparently
um this is this is
unbelievable and i'm sure we'll be able
to get somebody on to talk about it when
it comes to uh premier league um if boys
are playing if they're if they're with a
team and they're
um part of the youth squad then they can
play for free girls
have to pay 50 pounds a month is that
about it and only 43
of secondary schools allow girls to play
uh football during pe all of that stuff
i wanted to ask her about never mind
looking at today's headlines uh the us
president joe biden and china's xi
jinping may hold their fifth call as
soon as today white house officials have
said the long plan call will have a
broad agenda including russia's invasion
of ukraine which china has yet to
condemn and tensions over democratically
governed taiwan
a senior adviser to ukraine's president
zielenski says russia is shifting its
focus to strategic defense of areas it
already occupies rather than launching
offensives in areas of ukraine it has
yet to capture the advisor cited massive
redeployment of troops to
russian-occupied areas in the south of
ukraine as evidence of a shift in
strategy
and ukraine has warned russia to retreat
from the occupied city of kirsten or be
annihilated after severely damaging a
key bridge into the city ukrainian
forces used specialist american
long-range missiles known as highmars to
destroy a nepro river bridge that was
vital to importing supplies into the
city
cross-party group of mps has warned a
lack of menopause support is forcing
women out of the workforce now they've
called for a large-scale pilot of
menopause leave the women and equalities
committee which is chaired by the
conservative mp caroline knox said that
menopause should become a protected
characteristic under the equalities act
like pregnancy
thought that one in 20 covid patients
are left with long-term smell or taste
problems the british medical journal
says out of 550 million infections
worldwide in july 15 million may have
had lasting smell problems and 12
million taste problems
almost a third of girls in the uk can't
access free period products at their
school or college despite government
schemes being in place for several years
research by girl guiding has found the
charity is calling on the department of
education to make england's period
products scheme permanent currently the
scheme is only available until the end
of july
and something to look out for today the
commonwealth games kicking off we were
talking about that and uh
it's at birmingham's alexander stadium
there you go uh the ceremony is being
masterminded by stephen knight who you
may know as the brains behind the tv
show piggy blinders
birmingham-based which is set in
post-world war birmingham and speaking
of iconic culture exports from
birmingham the headline act of the
opening ceremony will be
these guys
[Music]
of course you did quick look at the
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
mainly dry although there'll be a few
showers but the weekend well what's
happening as far as that's concerned
looking more changeable fairly warm and
mostly dry now though
the weather sponsored by qatar
airworks okay i think we're doing the
paper so i'll get up and show you the
eye shows us a large eight by a 12-foot
painting believed to be the world's
largest watercolor it's believed it's
the first time the start of bethlehem
depicting the virgin mary and the baby
jesus has been out of its frame since
1912. it'll be on display in birmingham
museum in
2024. in the mail a wealthy landowner uh
has been accused of taking revenge on
his neighbors by building an
eight-foot-high wall of hay and straw
bale to block his view of their meadows
bit harsh it covers the entire 60-foot
width of his back garden looking at the
mirror showing us a very pesky tortoise
wither a knack for escapism apparently
as a result elmo's own felt the owner i
should say felt the need to tie a yellow
balloon around his body so she can keep
track of him when he makes a break for
it
coming up we're going to be speaking to
the barrister adam wagner about the
change in the law that will allow
broadcasters to show the sentencing
remarks of judges in court for the first
time stated i want to tell you about tv
cameras going to be allowed into
criminal courts for the first time today
with viewers able to watch the very
first live sentencing at 10 30 this
morning live on sky news from the old
bailey but first let's take a look at
some of the history behind this historic
decision photography was banned in all
uk criminal courts after a picture of
wife killer dr krippen standing in the
old bailey in 1910 was it was a sneak
picture and then it was subsequently
published
it wasn't until 1989 that camera access
was granted in the house of commons i
remember that very well 30 years later
the supreme court followed suit with the
court of appeal gaining access four
years after that
joining us now barrister at dougherty
street chambers adam wagner hi adams
good to see you this morning what do you
think is it a good idea
um yeah i think it's a really good idea
i think justice should be done and seen
to be done we've um that you know we've
been letting courts very gradually um
broadcast their hearings as you said
from the supreme court first over 10
years ago now and then the call to
appeal um people in actual fact have not
been that interested i don't think you
know it's mostly um
barristers making legal submissions and
what the public
i think would be really interested in is
seeing inside a criminal court and for
the first time today there are going to
be um cameras allowed into the old
bailly and first but only for sentencing
hearings so this is very a very small
step we're not getting we're not going
to get to a stage any time soon where
people can watch an entire trial like
they did with um the amber heard trial
or you know the ones from america maybe
o.j simpson that people remember were
still taking baby steps this was
announced years and years ago this move
so it's taken a while but they are baby
steps and i think they're steps in the
right direction
um we will only see the judge though
won't we for now
do you expect yes so at the moment it's
only the judge who will be giving a
sentencing remarks so at the end of a
criminal trial if the defendant is found
guilty they explain why they are
sentencing them in the way you know if
they're giving them a life sentence or
whatever they'll explain it and that's
all that's going to be seen just the
judge not the victims not witnesses not
not even the lawyers as far as i
understand it
so
it's very very limited it's almost the
most limited amount that could be shown
but i think
as with all these things once the courts
become used to having cameras as the um
appeal courts have become very used to
having cameras um and during coven in
fact um they've also been allowed to
broadcast through
teams or zoom to people who are
otherwise um that can't attend the
hearing so journalists and other lawyers
that sort of thing have been able to
attend by zoom so i think we're getting
closer and closer to a full trial being
broadcast
okay do you that's it's a natural
progression is it do you think because
of course when we saw cameras in the
house of commons to start within the
chamber it could only be a medium
close-up of one person you couldn't show
reaction et cetera et cetera and over
the years of course that has changed
yeah it's a good example it's a good
analogy because i think before cameras
went into the house of commons there was
a fear that um it would
demean the proceedings of the house of
commons and all of that and it
absolutely haven't it's hugely increased
access by the public who otherwise would
never go there and i think it should be
the same for a criminal trial anyone
that sat on a jury will will know how
different it is once you've seen the
inside of a court building most people
don't even know that judges in england
and wales don't use gavels so you know
so that's why
what you see on tv is often just wrong
so i think the more people have access
to the courts
um from their own homes i i think the
better although that will need to be
controlled where there are vulnerable
parties and that has to be carefully
thought of but those are problems that
can be solved and they're not um
irreconcilable
um what about the i mean i know that you
would never do this adam of course but
what about those uh of your colleagues
who might take the opportunity to be
grandstanding
um
no of course there are always been
grandstanding lawyers but they're you
know that they're probably grounded
stand in front of juries anyway um i
don't think the cameras would
necessarily make a difference but it
also might have the opposite effect they
might feel that they they would be
embarrassed to be um filmed
grandstanding or behaving in a you know
think about a more serious example what
about barristers who um can be quite
intimidating or judges that can be quite
intimidating towards witnesses they may
check their behavior a bit if they if
they know they're going to be filmed and
maybe this will end up on the evening
news so i i think that the um i think
those sorts of fears are ones that can
be that need to be tested i don't think
any of them are necessarily um the case
what about the safety and security of
jurors
yeah well i mean
i don't see any reason why jurors should
be um that why the identities of jurors
should ever be um broadcast and and for
anybody that watched the johnny depp and
amber had hammerhead
trial will know that the jurors were
never shown um in america they can then
give interviews so then they kind of
expose their own identities but
um i don't think that should ever be
shown there's no reason to do it
okay it's great to talk to you thanks
very much indeed adam thank you look
forward to seeing you on the telly
in court
thank you uh the crown court sentencing
remarks broadcast for the first time
later this morning with the sentencing
of ben oliver now that's going to be at
the old bailey uh what did he do well
uh found guilty of the manslaughter of
his grandfather we will bring you that
live here on sky news from 10 30 this
morning
meantime to the u.s where gun industry
leaders have been testifying in front of
congress for the first time in 20 years
about the crisis in gun violence
families of victims of mass shootings
watched on as manufacturers defended
their industry and products some of
which have been used in recent shootings
in the us here's our u.s correspondent
mark stone from washington
the families of the victims of america's
gun epidemic have spoken already about
their pain their loss
but they were back on capitol hill this
time to listen to the people who make
the guns who had agreed for the first
time in 20 years to answer lawmakers
questions how many more american
children
need to die
before your company will stop selling
assault weapons to civilians and
children the weapon of choice in most
mass murders in our country
congresswoman maloney i believe
that
these
murders
are local problems
that have to be solved locally
it would seem that in america's gun
debate there isn't space for contrition
over several hours the familiar lines
were drawn you from your ivory tower in
dc you know better we carry light arms
and we own them
we own them legally we intend to keep
them
pro-gun republican lawmakers
head-to-head with the reformists on the
democratic side mr daniel this
advertisement appears to depict
premeditated violence or murder from a
rooftop
this is how the gun companies have made
over one billion dollars selling assault
rifles over the past decade
allowing their customers to believe they
can be soldiers
does this from daniel defense whose
ar-15 rifle was used in uvalde
and this
any rational person
can see the direct lines from this
marketing to the troubled young men who
kill people in places like buffalo and
el paso and yuvaldi
outside the hearing no comfort for the
families if it was their child they
would do it
they would be moving mountains to get
this laws changed
honestly
these hearings are supposed to find
answers consensus to provoke change the
reality though so often seems to be that
they just expose the paralysis and the
polarization of politics here
the manufacturers and those politicians
who back them say it is the people not
their guns who are to blame mark stone
sky news in washington
don't forget cameras in court for the
first time criminal courts first time
making history today here on sky news 10
30 or thereabouts we will see a
sentencing just the judge uh at this
stage but it is the first time ever that
cameras have been allowed to broadcast
live from a criminal court 10 30 um this
morning here on sky news uh we are going
to be speaking to nadine doris the
cultural secretary who is up in
birmingham at the start of the opening
ceremony of the
commonwealth games 2022 that coming up
in just a second before that though
diamonds girl's best friend 170 carat
pink diamond has been discovered in
angola the largest of its kind found in
300 years the diamond was found in the
lulu alluvial diamond mine by the mine
owners lucapa diamond company the stones
are recovered from a riverbed and in the
past it has produced the two largest
diamonds ever found in the country
you can see uh the site here in angola
and all the machinery used to get the
diamonds out
looking at the front pages starting with
the mirror describing the possibility
that household energy bills could soon
hit 500 pounds a month the express
points out that this figure could add up
to as much as 3
850 pounds a year
the telegraph leads with a warning from
the uk's national security adviser that
china and the west could accidentally go
to nuclear war with each other as china
expands its nuclear arsenal how we'll
tell you more about that shortly and the
times has that story as well paper
saying the uk should talk to our enemies
to avoid the risk of nuclear war
the guardian hears from union
representatives warning that recent and
future rail strikes could soon lead to a
general strike if disagreements aren't
resolved
trying to make the point with you and
give you the opportunity to reply to a
report that i was reading about the
legacy of sporting events around the
world and how
they promise a lot but actually once the
bandwagon moves on the people that are
left behind don't have what they are
promised for example 30 000 homes
promised for london 2012 only 13 000
have so far been delivered how would you
respond to reports like that
well
so i i would question that actually
because so much as you only got to go
into east london to be able to see the
legacy that was left behind by the 2012
olympics and what i would say here is
over the past year i've visited the
samwell aquatic center which has been
purpose built for the commonwealth games
here in birmingham and that's being left
for the people of the local community to
use i don't know if you've been there
with your
with your cruise yet but it is an
amazing it's an amazing facility that's
being left behind you know we've
invested as a government over 600
million pounds into birmingham and the
commonwealth games and a huge amount of
that will be left behind in terms of
legacy and ongoing legacy and it's
interesting you should mention the 2012
games okay because i think that's i
think most people can remember what they
were doing in 2012 they know how they
felt at that time and you speak to
people about the olympics it's a very
positive story they have to tell and i
think the investment here in birmingham
and in the west midlands will leave a
similar legacy not just in house
building or in aquatic centers but in
the good that's created for the
community and how positive people feel
about birmingham and actually shining a
light on birmingham putting birming in
the west midlands on the map and that is
just as important because that's the
soft
power impact that something like the
commonwealth games brings to a city like
birmingham and a region like the west
midlands and that's all positive good
stuff
um you staying with your brief you
talked about the lionesses and we're all
hoping that they were okay i'm being
told i'm can i just ask you about the
line
oh yeah i just want i just want to ask
you about the lionesses if i may uh only
for this this is definitely on your
brief uh 44 of secondary schools in
england allow girls to play football is
that something that you will look at
yeah i mean i've been to a number of uh
schools actually with girls football
teams and and i think education schools
are taking a really positive attitude
towards women in sport you know women in
sport they don't get the same amount of
sponsorship attention media time and and
just a recognition for how port and
women's sport is and i think the
commonwealth games the lionesses
particularly on sunday night they are
going to in their own way help to to
keep that progress going and to move
forward both football and other other
sports which we know women just don't
feel represented in so
you know the commonwealth games it's a
good positive news story all round for
women for um for the inclusivity that
this commonwealth games is representing
hosting together both female sports and
um and parasports and it's all happening
in those 11 days taking place here in
birmingham and it's and it's just all
positive good news for sport for women
and for birmingham particularly would
you like to see eurovision in birmingham
now i do have to go i'm really sorry
would you like to see eurovision in
birmingham as well sorry would you
i
couldn't possibly comment okay i could
possibly comment
thank you very much see you soon okay
thanks a lot thank you thanks a lot
tried tried met office published its
annual report and it shows the impact of
global warming on the uk climate is
worsening let's find out more should we
mike kendon climate scientist at the met
office is with us now what did the
report say good morning
hello well we look at 2021 and we
compare it to the long-term climate
series we have for the uk which go all
the way back to 1884. so 2021 actually
was fairly near average for temperature
for the uk if we compared to the most
recent 30-year period 1991-2020
but what's really interesting is that if
we compare it in the context of our full
series back to 1884 before 1990 it would
have been
one of the warmest years on record so
what we regard now as a fairly normal
year for the uk
uh before 1990 would have been unusually
warm so our perception of what is normal
is changing as our climate changes and
for the uk
excuse me
for the uk we've uh all 10 warmest years
for the uk have occurred this century in
that series we have a very long running
central england temperature series which
goes back more than three three
centuries the 21st century so far has
been warmer than the previous three
centuries so our climate is changing
is the uk making any progress towards
our climate goals
well look the science on this is clear
that um in in order to avoid the worst
effects of dangerous climate change we
need to keep global warming below one
and a half degrees and the um the the
the longer it takes to make changes the
harder it will be to achieve that target
what this report looks at is the
observations what has already happened
in terms of the uk's climate um as i've
mentioned we've seen changes in
temperature we've also seen changes in
rainfall for example
our atmosphere as it warms it can retain
more moisture so we're seeing that our
climate is getting wetter but the
distribution of rainfall is also
changing so we're seeing more rainfall
extremes and in just over the last 10
years we've seen the wettest february
the wettest april the wettest june
the wettest november and the wettest
december on record 5 out of 12 months
in just over a decade so that really
shows that our climate is changing
um yeah what more do we need to do we're
looking at 2050 net zero carbon by then
that's what uh that's what the british
government has said that they're hoping
for but you know it's a long way off
well that's just to put this in
perspective last week we've had an
absolutely incredible heatwave for the
uk really unprecedented in the moments
of uk climate history we've had 40
degrees recorded for the first time and
frankly that's put a coach and horses
through the gap between previous records
for long-running uh stations records
absolutely smashed
what we know from the science is that uh
moving ahead into the future some of uh
you know we are committed to a certain
amount of warming and heat waves like
this will become
more intense and more prolonged through
time and so clearly that is a concern
because obviously heat waves like this
if we think of the impacts of the heat
that we had last week
for example on rail infrastructure on
elderly and vulnerable people
you know this was a relatively brief
spike in heat but imagine if it lasted
uh you know over a two week period the
impacts could be really severe so it's
obviously important that we in the met
office provide the best available
science to government uh using our high
resolution climate models out to the end
of the century so that we can provide
them with the best available advice as
to how to respond to this
okay thank you thanks very much indeed
for joining us on the program thank you
pleasure
obviously one of the topics will be um
debating when we have our leaders debate
here on sky news next thursday at 8 00
p.m when we see wishy sunak and this
trusts uh together head to head if
you've got a question you'd like to take
part we do have a live studio audience
with us
and we'd be thrilled to hear from you
check it out on our website we've got a
barcode as well that we can share with
you in the next hour we can do it now
there you go um hosted by me
next thursday week today eight o'clock
sky
buildings in west london the battle for
number 10.